Ally what do you say to the women that
say my husband isn't my boss there is no
need to be submissive you're a team I
understand where they're coming from but
these same women don't understand that
oftentimes they'll put their husbands on
the back burner for like an actual boss
in real life that they have to submit to
and they constantly ask their husbands
to modify their lives for that meanwhile
the dude is forgotten he's absolutely
sexless and she's feeding him out of the
microwave that's the problem if you can
work and love your man equally you want
to talk about equalism right if you can
do that then good but most women can't
most women can't even push the power
button on an air fryer